[Music]
james is with us to start off this hour
james is in wilmington north carolina hi
james how are you
hi dave good yourself better than i
deserve what's up awesome
um so i was curious
i'm 38 married um
and my 401 is about a little over 600
000
and i didn't know if i should borrow
from it to pay off my house
and or car no no
okay i would stop adding to it
stop adding to it temporarily until you
get your car paid off
even if the company matches even if the
company matches it
you need to get your car paid off how
much do you own your car
uh just bought it to 32. and you
borrowed all of that
what's that yes do you have any money no
no i haven't borrowed it i haven't
borrowed it uh
i thought you said borrow against your
401k to pay off your car
if i should borrow against my 401 to pay
it off
yeah so have you do you owe money on
your car
yes 32 000 you borrowed money on the car
that's what i was talking about
so how much money do you have i have
about
3 000 in savings and 10 000 for like an
emergency
okay well james we teach a process that
is the shortest distance between where
you are
and wealth you've done an extremely good
job
with your investing you've done a very
poor job
with some of the other areas of your
money so you're way ahead on investing
in your way behind
on some of the other things your goal
should be to be debt free
not counting your house and have an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses
before you start investing so we're
temporarily going to stop investing
temporarily i want you to hold one
thousand dollars back as a beginner
starter emergency fund
and i want you to throw everything else
at the car what do you make
uh my base salary is 71.5
but with overtime usually about 90 a
year
okay so how quick if we throw ten
thousand dollars at this car or
uh twelve thousand dollars at this car
how quickly are you uh
gonna knock out the other twenty
thousand like
six months yeah possibly yeah
just depends on my wife's business too
so okay
good oh i'm sorry i didn't ask what she
made but what does she make okay
uh she makes she pays herself twelve
thousand for her base salary
and then it just uh all the clients her
practice
sees so it kind of varies roughly what
does she make a year
taxable income oh i have no idea
more than me more than 90.
yes okay yeah then you should pay off
the car within a month or two
or three something like that and then
you need the baby step three
build an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses
and then you would start putting fifteen
percent of your income away towards
retirement
that's baby step four five is start
saving for kids college if that's
applicable in your situation and six is
we begin to any other money we can be
beyond 15 of your income that you can
find any other money you can get your
hands on i would get the house paid off
early and that walks you right up what
we call our baby steps
they're outlined in in my best-selling
book called the total money makeover
i'll give you a copy of it
hold on kelly will pick up and we'll
send you a copy of the total money
makeover it shows you exactly
how to work the baby steps exactly what
to do